he is a surefire first ballot hall of
famer and uh i could go through
all of his accolades from his playing
career but i'll just say he's here
uh now as part of uh copper compression
but also a colleague of ours now in the
media as he's joined nbc sports he is
the
great drew brees how are you drew that's
good
i'm good rich how are you i am that's
that's a great that's a crazy thought
i'm
i'm joining the media world with you huh
you're part of the paparazzi now drew
that's exactly what you're doing
but here's one of the things too is i
love interviews like this because
you can no longer when i ask you about
your career say you know what i'll just
think about it when it's all over
um you can't use that answer that
answer's gone drew you can't use that
answer yeah anymore
so that that's that's true what do you
i mean do you ever you know i don't know
if i've caught you while driving
at any point but did you ever just like
look over the steering wheels you've
been driving over the last couple weeks
or
last couple months since i you know you
knew that you were you were done and
just go holy crap i did all that
does that happen uh
there's there's definitely been some
moments of reflection i i'd say
more so in in recent weeks um you know
right when the season ended i try to
just
get away and take some time with the
family but um
yeah certainly the the announcement um
made it all very real
and uh you know had had some time to
to spend with um you know those who have
been a part of the journey and
kind of really put some of my thoughts
you know
on paper and and just feel a lot of
those emotions and
really really an incredible journey um
the last 20 years
and and really beyond that too i mean i
think when you
i think part of retirement too is just
thinking that all that has gone into
um that career and so it goes even
well before actually making it to the
nfl
you know so many experiences through
college and back to high school and even
you know growing up you know what you
dream and aspire to do and
having had the chance to to live out you
know those dreams in my athletic career
was was pretty remarkable so what is
your
proudest accomplishment now that you
have the ability to say i look back and
i did this
because you can no longer say i'll think
about it when it's over because it is in
fact over
so what do you got for me drew you know
um
i'd say i'd say one of one of the things
that
one of the things that really uh kind of
just touched my heart
you know especially over the last couple
weeks is just all the people that have
reached out
and and expressed the influence that i
had on them as a teammate or a friend
um you know during this journey and so
just having a chance to
to re to read those and and relive some
of those moments and and also
just think about those relationships you
know that that's that's really what it's
all about
um i feel very fortunate to have been
surrounded by so many great people along
the way
you know coaches and teammates
friendships that i'll have for a
lifetime
and just thinking back on the way that
those guys influenced me and
motivated me and inspired me along the
way too what about the numbers because
you're going to be able to sit there on
the football night in america set drew
and say i wish i had that 17th game you
know what i mean like you're you're
all these records are gonna be 16 game
records that
um that uh means everyone else has an
asterisk
next to theirs forevermore so
with the 17-game schedule coming which
of the numbers
accomplishments are you most proud of
that you were able to do
um you know i honestly the
i think you if you play long enough you
know a lot of that stuff adds up
right um you know i i really approached
every season
like i i wanted to get better you know
there was
there was i would always end each season
and before i started
um training that that upcoming off
season i
i would always take kind of a hard look
a very analytical look at
that previous season and where the areas
that i think i
that i needed to improve and then i
would incorporate that into my training
and just my overall thought process
and you know the numbers didn't always
reflect those improvements and yet
i i think as long as deep down i knew
that i was continuing to
to grow and learn and get better that's
what was most important
and so what comes along with that is
consistency
um i think the way that i wanted to be
perceived by others was they knew
exactly what to expect out of me
every time i stepped in the building and
every time i stepped on the field
and what they were going to get from me
in the game what they were going to get
for me in clutch situations
i wanted to be that consistent performer
that consistent influence
and i i think that's probably honestly
what i'm most
proud of um is not any specific
statistic or number but rather
the consistency that went with you know
my approach and the way that i
i looked at my job and the way that i
looked at being a teammate for others
drew brees here on the rich eisen show
so why did you
take all that time to retire you know
i'm sure you're aware people were
wondering if you were still thinking
about it
were you still thinking about it at all
no
no i you know i i knew i knew that was
it
um it it felt like it was time um
i just you know i i wanted to i wanted
to give it justice you know i wanted to
i kind of i think everybody maybe has
this image in their mind as to how
how they make that announcement or how
it all kind of goes down and
and i guess i i hadn't i hadn't really
put a ton of thought into that
you know when when the season ended and
so my my first focus was just to spend a
lot of time with my family and
and reflect and and then just
kind of let it come to me you know and
and
and not just go rush out and do
something and then
you know think back on it later and say
ah you know i wish i would have done it
a different way
well you know your your boy todd durkin
who's uh who's been training you for a
very long time put that video you
pushing the sled where you damn little
went into traffic it looked like
made us all think that you were you know
preparing to come back
drew he he stirred the pot a little bit
didn't he no sure did
yeah certainly i thought you were going
into traffic too
so uh yeah yeah me too that
i i've never i've never really gone that
route i've never really gone downhill
which what i would recommend is going
uphill first
and then go downhill to finish it out
once your legs are dead
not sprint to the bottom and then after
struggle
all the way back up you know that's
that's not the recommended route
yes i would i would i would now go talk
about
early retirement drew i mean that was
very cool
you know no but you know i
i i still love to train i still love to
challenge myself
um i mean i'm having a chance to do a
lot of things that
you know i've probably been putting on
hold um
while i was playing football like um
i went mountain biking the other day i
went skiing doing this e-foiling
hydrofoiling stuff
um so i don't know it's uh
i'm still gonna challenge myself i'm
still gonna still gonna work out hard
um still gonna wanna compete just find
different ways to do it
so and then of course you you did time
your retirement to be on the anniversary
of your arrival in new orleans and part
of you the thing drew and you know i've
never said this even in private but
that's the most impressive about your
career is how it started
and how it ended and what you did to
become a surefire first ballot hall of
famer which nobody thought you
were or had a chance to on the day that
you
signed with new orleans so i guess my
question for you here is how close were
you to signing with miami
ever did that almost happen at all
and say well so i mean i'd say this
there was there was
two there was really two moments where i
thought it was going to happen
so when i came out uh of college
i remember miami had the 26th pick
in the first round and my head coach joe
tiller at purdue
one of his best friends in football
was a scout for the miami dolphins and
so they talked frequently
and that scout had told joe tiller that
if i was available at 26 the dolphins
would be taking me
that like without a doubt they were
taking me so
when draft day came around there were
some teams that were that were talking
about potentially taking me maybe mid
late first round
but i knew that kind of that backstop
was the miami dolphins
right so if i was still available at 26
i was going to be a dolphin well
sure enough pick 26 rolls around and i'm
sitting there by the phone wait for it
to ring and it never rings and
they end up drafting jamar fletcher from
wisconsin a db
who was a really good db by the way
picked me off a couple times in college
um so i guess i couldn't fault him for
that but
that was the first opportunity and then
obviously when i was uh when i was
leaving san diego
after my injury in o5 really the two
teams that
that came calling were the miami
dolphins with coach nick saban
and the new orleans saints and i think
just on the surface
before visiting either team before you
know meeting with
either coach just on the surface
miami seemed like the obvious choice
right they were an up and coming team
nick saban super talented head coach
handled the defensive side of the ball i
was familiar with a couple of their
offensive staff
they were running the exact same offense
that we were running in san diego which
i liked
and and so and then you know you're
going to miami
right and then versus on the flip side
here's new orleans been devastated by
hurricane katrina
um new head coach sean payton that
nobody's ever heard of
um until just again on the surface it
was like all right well miami's the
obvious choice you know and that was
until
i had a chance to really dive in and and
meet both sides and
and visit new orleans and and really
feel that that was going to be so much
more than football so
yeah those were those are two instances
where miami
i thought miami was really going to
happen drew brees here on the rich eisen
show dennis leary and mike florio coming
up in
our numbers two and three right here on
the rich eisen show our radio affiliates
are going to take a break in about
10 seconds time and then a couple more
minutes left with drew brees
which uh you know right here on nbc
sports on peacock
right here on the rich eisen show
so drew uh tell me in the couple minutes
i have left i know you've got
a relationship you want to talk about
with copper compression i'll give you
the floor on that
yeah copper compression has been a big
part of my my training
and my recovery you know late in my
career and um
i think i'm gonna probably need it now
more so than ever as i continue to stay
very active and very competitive it's
the number one seller on amazon
um and other e-commerce sites and so
highly recommend that uh that people try
it out if
there's somebody like me who wants to
remain healthy and active
as possible yes well you know i gave you
an opportunity earlier drew to say
what your uh achievement that you're
most proud of
in the nfl was um i was really hoping
that you would say
it was throwing a piece of bread through
the rich eisen show lacquered square
bread
at super bowl 50 as you uh destroyed it
and showed off the accuracy that's part
of the reason why you're going to the
hall of fame
but i just assume you just you meant
that by not saying it
it was sort of unspoken right drew yeah
yeah
absolutely and and so there's my on the
field accomplishments
yes and then there's my in studio
accomplishments
right had you specified it would have
been
immediately rolled off my tongue well
well i'm i'm glad
i'm glad we have the chance to talk
about it now because it was
certainly one of my better memories of
any
um in studio performance and uh
i i i i think i think we should have i i
feel like that should be framed
somewhere like um i mean do we have that
framed in in the in the rich eyes in
studio somewhere
brockman did we the bread never made it
red never made it back unbelievable we
have a photo of it all put back together
see drew you'll learn when you're in
television you just blame it on your
staff
you can just do that yeah i got you i
yeah yeah where where were they on that
one but we do have a photograph of it
all put together just to show how you
you you damn near bull's-eye the whole
thing and i'll just say this and
letting you go you know mike tarico uh
who you're going to be working with
quite a bit
uh i've known him for a quarter century
he's as great as they come and sam
floods group
at nbc sports terrific but as long as
they don't bring out any bread
you've set the bar very high for
yourself okay drew just saying that
i uh i appreciate that i'm i'm really
excited about
working with mike and sam and the entire
uh nbc team they are first class and um
you know we're we're getting started on
a lot of that stuff right now so i'm
excited about the next chapter here with
them
you're the best drew thanks for joining
appreciate it hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here